Uh, welcome everybody. Thanks for attending
our talk.
I'm Ryan. I'm a sales engineer at
Chronosphere,
and if you don't know, Chronosphere is an
observability company.
Uh, we're focused on open source data
collection, performance and reliability at
scale,
uh, and control over your telemetry, only
paying for what you need.
And recently we've had a lot of success at
AI companies and in AI use cases.
What we're gonna talk about in this short talk,
uh, is an intro to AI observability,
the different patterns, um, use
cases we're seeing,
um, and kind of how to use observability to
prevent some pitfalls.
Not going to be able to go super deep into product
demonstration, unfortunately, but definitely encourage
you guys to check out the Chronosphere booth, where
we're demoing our AI guided capabilities,
um, and some of our other new features there as well.
So first, before we get into the use cases
themselves, we're gonna kind of overview
what we're seeing from a market perspective.
So from our perspective, we've broken the market
down into 4 core buckets. We're seeing
model builders.
These are people who are building foundation models
that everyone else is building on top of and consuming,
GPU providers who are tailoring
GPU infrastructure, uh, around AI
inference, model training, and fine tuning
use cases.
AI natives who are building products from the ground
up around AI technology,
uh, and then our feature builders who have
existing products and capabilities, where
they're adding AI functionality,
um, into those existing product lines.
And across the board, one thing to highlight, observability
has always been hard,
uh, continues to be a struggle,
and AI is just adding complexity,
adding a layer on top of that.
All of your existing large scale cloud
native problem patterns
definitely still exist and are at the core of
AI observability use cases.
Going into a little bit more depth, um,
on those challenges,
what we're seeing in existing large cloud
native, uh, workloads,
massive scale,
really mission critical reliability,
high performance,
uh, a lot of troubleshooting complexity
across distributed systems,
observability costs and data volume
control, and then managing cardinality
as your infrastructure changes.
Some of the new AI specific challenges we're
talking about are actually around model
behavior, making sure the model's accurate, doing
what you expect it to do,
managing the token economics to actually get an
ROI on the use case you're attacking,
um, and then understanding complex dependencies,
especially if you're using MCP,
RAG, energenic architectures.
And then lastly, if you're managing your own GPU
infrastructure, um, that's largely a new
component for many organizations.
So we're gonna dive into our first use case, which
is model training.
Um, everything in this use case also applies
if you're doing fine tuning.
But what really matters here is training efficiency,
model performance as far as the end result.
Um, the model is the product of the training.
And then GPU utilization,
these resources are extremely costly.
Um, so it's critical you're actually getting the
right utilization from your investment.
Uh, a build here, let me click through.
So, a quick overview before we get into the observability
side, um, of the standard model development
life cycle.
I'm definitely trivializing it a little bit here,
but we're taking large data sets, putting that
into a large compute infrastructure
with GPU accelerators, and running
distributed training jobs in that infrastructure,
with the goal of producing a trained model,
uh, that we can then put out into the wild and get value
from. Once
the model's complete, the next step is actually hosting
your inference service, whether that's externally
or internally, more as like a platform team.
Um, but this is where as a user, I can say, hey,
here's my description or image of a cat,
and my model can infer or predict, yes,
this is indeed a cat.
Simple. And
if we look at, um, you know, a basic architecture
of how you might go about this,
this is all about scale, reliability, and performance.
Um, and what we're seeing in the market is,
uh, the more training cycles, the more compute
you have,
the bigger and better model you get.
And efficient training becomes a competitive advantage,
especially when everybody has access to roughly equal
compute infrastructure.
Looking a little bit at where the problem patterns
start to occur, and where we can start thinking
about observability to prevent them, um,
starts with our data sets.
So understanding that a small amount
of inaccurate or invalid data
can poison your entitled, uh, entire
training cycle.
Uh, so understanding the metadata around your data
sets, measuring how one data set versus
another impacts the results you get, super
critical.
And then similarly, we have data ingestion
services.
Um, and if these are slow or have spikes
and errors, it's going to bottleneck, again, your
entire training pipeline.
And then we have the model training jobs themselves.
Um, this is very similar to a traditional
service or any other job you might be monitoring.
Uh, need to correlate infrastructure issues
with the outcome of training.
And then on the far right-hand side,
we see the GPUs, the dollar sign on fire.
Again, continuing to highlight, if you have
downtime or low utilization, not
only wasting money,
uh, but you're slowing down your time to market and
getting the value from what you're investing in.
So at the end of the day, kind of asking yourself,
are we maximizing our training efficiency
to stay competitive in every way that we can?
Uh, now jumping to Chronosphere and tying
this a little bit more closely to observability,
uh, what we're looking at here is a Chronosphere
lens service page.
This is interesting to us because what Chronosphere
is doing is saying, hey,
I'm detecting GPU metrics
from the Nvidia DCGM, uh, Prometheus
exporter.
We're getting utilization,
temperature,
error stats. Um, but
we know from our labeling strategy,
this is supporting a specific training
job. We're also getting the
training metrics from our Hotel Python SDKs.
That's giving us training accuracy, gradient
norms, samples per second.
And having all the information here lets
us quickly understand kind of end to end
what's happening in our training job.
We're looking at this from the perspective of a human
looking at dashboards and service pages,
but all the same value grouping and analysis
applies to our AI troubleshooting tooling,
um, our MCP and Agentic integrations.
Uh, so that's super critical to think about.
And throughout,
low latency alerting. If you have XID
errors, and you have GPUs that are malfunctioning,
the time from that malfunctioning GPU,
um, to getting an alert in front of an operator who
can remediate is absolutely critical.
And then again, throughout,
only keeping the data that we actually need
to accomplish the use case we're pursuing.
All right, and again, this is a scroll down of
the same service page.
And I'm highlighting because we have distributed
tracing with Otel,
we get out of the box this dependency map,
and we can see right away if there's a spike
in errors, a slowdown. Um,
with a data ingestion service.
And we have all of our telemetry in one place. So
not only do we know there's an issue,
but we have all the logs, the events, the metrics, the
traces to dig into,
um, and really correlate, identify the root
cause, um, ultimately maximize
the, uh, minimize, sorry, the training downtime
and maximize your GPU utilization.
Cool. So we have a trained or fine-tuned
model. That's awesome,
doesn't provide a ton of value, unless we
can put it in front of users, uh, by
hosting our model with an inference hosting
use case.
So what matters here, Service reliability.
People are going to be building on top of this, they
need it to work, or they're going to pursue other alternatives.
Uh, on the same note, it has to be fast.
If it's not fast, they're waiting around, they're going to use
the next tool.
And ultimately, we need this to be scalable. We're investing
all this time and energy into training and hosting.
Uh, we don't want to support small scale use cases.
We want this to scale to many users.
So another architecture diagram here,
this one will feel very familiar to a traditional
cloud native service.
We just kind of have inference plugged in at the back end
there. But users need fast and accurate
responses across multiple client devices.
Um, the services are relying on this, so
uptime, performance is critical.
Uh, and namely, this last bullet point,
incidents and outages can be very high
impact, high visibility when we're talking
about inference.
You don't want to be in the news because your AI is giving
incorrect or harmful information.
So again, looking at our problem patterns,
front-end issues in our different UIs,
uh, upstream dependencies,
all of these supporting services can impact our reliability,
network issues, and then again, keeping GPUs
kind of always in sight when we're talking about AI use
cases,
a little bit less critical for inference, might
impact only, uh, you know, a smaller set of users,
uh, but still ultimately important to keep track of.
So jumping back into Chronosphere, now we're
in the perspective
of a platform team,
self-hosting some inference.
We still care about all of our red metrics
like we would with any other service,
request, errors, duration.
But we also want some way to evaluate
and benchmark, uh, the accuracy
and health of inference itself.
And that's what you see here with our hallucination rate,
biased response rate, and toxic response rates.
So again, we have all the telemetry in one place, we're
kind of correlating these different things.
And one, piece of feedback, positive
feedback we get from our customers
is any graph in chronosphere, you
can click into and access
our anomaly detection feature called differential
diagnosis.
And for example, that spike down there,
um, you're able to quickly identify which
label is most uniquely associated
with that anomaly.
Uh, is that a build version, a cluster
version, um, container or something
else? That's the actionable piece
of information that often gets lost in
the noise, um, of a large observability implementation.
So we're gonna start shifting gears. We've talked about
training and fine tuning models.
Uh, that's in our view, a smaller set of
organizations. What most organizations are
actually doing is consuming and
building on top of inference.
Um, so first, let's define this term AI
native.
Uh, I think it's definitely subjective at this point.
But our view when we say AI native,
is people who are building from day one,
designing around the AI technologies.
One fun way to think about this and kind of test it.
Uh, is if you think of a product person
or a founder, and they say, hey, what if
we built a,
and then you put any product category in there,
it could be an IDE, an HR tool,
um, anything,
and you say, but with AI,
most likely, that's going to be an AI native product.
So we can see up top here our traditional architecture,
we have strict schemas and data models,
using CRD rest architectures.
Implementing these capabilities one by one
behind endpoints and then accessing them through our
different uh client devices.
But with AI right on the bottom here,
we don't need to be as concerned or as
strict with our data models,
and we don't need to implement every single capability
individually,
because the LLM has the ability to reason,
take requests dynamically that aren't pre-implemented,
um, and use data that might not
be structured.
So what we're seeing now is functionality built
around inference and tokens,
uh, reasoning and rag capabilities, and
then really optimizing around your prompt
and context engineering.
Uh, and then another thing you might notice, startup URLs
are now maybe innovativeguy.AI
instead of disruptiveproduct.io, right?
Um, some other terms, we've talked about these a lot
already. But just to make sure we're kind of level setting,
when we say tokens, we mean essentially the word
count going in and out of the LLM.
This is used to gauge throughput, um, also
to calculate pricing.
Uh, some other key concepts are evaluations.
This is taking the inputs into an LLM,
looking at the output you got,
and evaluating if it's what you expect, if
it's healthy, um,
And doing what you needed to do.
And then lastly, rag or retrieval
augmented generation,
extending the knowledge or data
available to a foundational, uh, excuse me, a
foundation model,
um, through external data sets.
So, finally getting to the inference health
use case, home stretch here.
Uh, what matters?
Typically, you're looking at
my model accuracy or performance,
and you're comparing that directly against
the token economics and the cost,
uh, that's required to achieve those outcomes.
And ultimately, what we're seeing AI natives really strive
for is product differentiation
through the use of AI.
Otherwise, AI might not be the tool to solve
that problem.
So we're gonna go through some examples, um, of
some concrete inference health issues that observability
can help solve.
So the first one is probably the most common we all hear
about, which is hallucinations.
I think a great example of this, straightforward,
asking it what is OTE?
And the LLM tells me OTE is a 3D
printed telescope.
Wholeheartedly incorrect, but the LLM
is confidently stating this as a fact.
If you don't have a way to measure and evaluate
this, um, you have no idea how
often your users are experiencing that.
Another one that can be, uh, even potentially
more dangerous
is if you have bias, and you're starting to use
inference in things like hiring workflows,
um, agentic, HR, right?
Uh, and there's bias you're not aware of,
which candidate should I hire?
And it says you should only hire hockey fans.
Maybe if you're hiring for a hockey coach or something
like that, it makes sense. Um, otherwise,
this could be really harmful.
And then at the end here, less about the behavior
of the inference,
more about those token economics, um,
but excess token consumption.
So if I'm asking a simple question,
what letter comes after A?
And the model tells me the letter A
is, the letter after A is B followed
by C,
you can count the number of excess words and characters,
and at scale, that adds up to just wasted
money and cost.
So, kind of double clicking one level further,
um, why do these things happen? If we
start with hallucinations again,
largely this is something that's related to your own prompting,
um, and your own usage of the model.
Could be inaccuracies in training data,
and then the lack of tools for a rag,
um,
Lack of update information. It doesn't have the
knowledge, so it tries to invent an answer,
um, that's not available to it.
For bias, if you have bias in your training data,
they're going to have bias in your inference.
You might not have evaluations or guardrails at all,
or you might just have ambiguous prompts that's
not protecting against any, um,
uh, bias that does exist.
Excess token consumption, if you've use an
MCP server, you've probably seen a
model spin its wheels and infinitely
make requests, um, and just burn
a ton of tokens.
If you have that type of thing happening inside
an agentic workflow,
again, you can scale it. Um, that's a
lot of wasted costs. You could be spending on GPUs
or elsewhere.
You also just might not have output filtering.
You might not be specifying a response format.
So the LLM doesn't know what you want it to do.
So it's guessing, uh, and producing some waste.
And then if we think back to our example where you might also
be hosting the inference yourself,
you can look at your temperature settings, um,
inference and model configurations,
um, always keep an eye on the quality of training
data, and your GPU performance
actually can affect how the model behaves.
It can restrict tool calls, it can change the
behavior, uh, and impact the accuracy of
responses.
All right, back to chronosphere one more time. How
can we use observability, um, to kind of help
us protect against these pitfalls?
What we're looking at here is an OTel trace.
Uh, this is instrumented,
um, with a library called
Open Inference by RS AI.
What that does is give us everything we get in a standard
OTel trace, but it also grabs LLM
specific attributes that we can do a lot
of additional analysis on.
So anywhere in this trace, if there's a traditional
service error or a hallucination, bias,
etc.
this whole line will go red, and you'll know right away
where in your agent,
uh, reasoning or request the issue is.
And then we can jump in,
create trends, use our anomaly detection
again, um.
But on the right hand side, we see the span details.
When I talk about these LLM specific
attributes, what do I mean?
Uh, I mean stuff like this, we can see which model,
which model version,
the actual prompts, uh, inputs
and outputs.
We can feed those into evaluation systems
like Phoenix, you can create your own,
uh, you can even run evaluations at the code level.
We also get all of our token counts,
uh, and we get these assessment attributes for
hallucination,
bias, or toxicity.
What this lets me do is drive all these useful
trends, uh, and start analyzing the
data. So if I'm an AI native product,
What do I care about, right? You might care about choosing
the right model for the job,
so we can see what's the average cost per
request broken down by model.
We can compare that over time.
So maybe one new release actually switches
this up. And the way you're doing your prompting
makes it so that Grok's cheaper, um,
than an alternative, for example.
These are the type of things you always want to keep an eye on,
so you can make data-driven decisions and always
improve your product and your implementation.
Then at the bottom here, we've talked a lot about the hallucinations
already. Um,
but again, maybe you make a change, maybe the model
provider makes a change, and all of a sudden you
see a spike in hallucinations.
You need to action that and pull it out of prod right
away. This is something that
I think traditionally AI and ML teams were
focused on.
But now if you're an SRE if you're a,
um, support operator, and
you see this happening in production,
speed of actioning that becomes critical to
stay out of the news stories.
OK. And in closing, we talked about
a lot of different data.
Um, one thing to highlight, Chronosphere does
not have a proprietary agent.
All the data we used, uh, in this
talk was open source
from open telemetry, SDKs and collectors,
Nvidia, DCGM Prometheus exporter,
Cube State metrics, Prometheus node
exporters,
the Open inference SDK. Again, that's from,
uh, Arise AI,
uh, they're open-source products, Phoenix AI
and then fluent Bit for our logs.
That's it. That's everything I wanted to cover. Hopefully, it was
valuable. Uh, really appreciate you guys listening
to the talk and hope you have a great rest
of your reinvent.
Thank you.
All right, thank you, Ryan.